[Music]
hello my name is Lee Harvey I'm from
Mexico t-shirt today I will present the
app to you and the name is intelligent
Chinese learning so this app is to aim
foreigners to learn Chinese you know
that glottal passage is one in the whole
world like make is between different
people from different countries speaking
two languages by increasing trends today
so it's really important to learn
foreign language so intelligent change
learning is a native eye so to provide
you a mobile experience to learn Chinese
and enter anywhere then it starts from
the pronunciation it will teach you the
upper bite the vocabulary and grammar
and in fact as you can see then we call
a virtual teacher here so you can tell
which the virtual teacher on specific
scenarios like this one so you come by
maybe you want to buy some fruits
I will give you some key words and all
the citizens you can repeat and learn
and on the tech cart we've got a AI
technology right
so they speaks recognition and natural
language precisely so you can see this
chart and input a Chinese learners page
and we'll break it to phonetic and
prosonic and these some technology to
gestate lurches the weekly you give it a
score the sit back always that you can
improve what we are doing is bad so you
can see this is the video that we
recorded and this is the virtual teacher
and this is the screen of the eye
I think the F will do a good job to
Infernus to learn Chinese right McMaster
that you can try that out
thank you